so back to Thomas Hobbs and you remember
last class that we met I said that that
hops in a way presents a challenge to
ethics as we've thought of it so he
Hobbs is right that means that Aristotle
Plato Thomas Aquinas have to be certain
basic things also the people that were
going to study after Hobbes like the
utilitarian as for starting Bentham and
mill it hogs is right they have to be
wrong certain really fundamental things
why is it well the last class we looked
at Hobbes understanding of human nature
concepts what do you remember from what
did you say the good once again I think
you thinking Thomas Aquinas easy to mix
up Thomas Hobbes Thomas Aquinas
hops typically the guys weird kind of
way he's a materialist
yeah so we have a name for this basic
and vehicle relativism whatever it's
good just light and beautiful any of
those sorts of things are relative to
the society or to the individual there
is no such thing as a standard of right
and wrong per se in nature whereas
somebody that Thomas Aquinas like yeah
through there is God created everything
he could in the actual walk to human
beings that they can discover how does
goods like when the actual walked he
means something very very different so
now if we don't agree on really basic
things of what's good what's bad
we're probably gonna run into some
problems it's not just in society it's
just getting to society problems yeah
Hobbes talks about what he calls of a
state of nature a natural condition
Manorville everything human
and when were in the state of nature
if you think about human beings like
look around in your classmates how are
they similar to you we're going to other
than being at Marist College and smarter
you all have some same purpose you all
do that that's going to be very
important you all have the ability to
reason and that's coming from your human
form right that that actually culminates
in this capacity to look like your
physical strength some of you are
stronger sort of you're weaker so many
very athletes when there's you know
doing other things
the others are probably physically
stronger and more endurance but now
imagine where I'm left that survivor
island we all see in the show survivor
sometimes in Iowa
let's say was very brutal it wasn't like
the TV show well the TV show and they
don't really punch each other or set
traps for each other but man they're
scarce resources you know you were
really a while you might cooperate with
them where you might kill and if
somebody's an athlete they're physically
stronger than you and let's now if you
don't make the assumption they have to
turn smart that's not a good assumption
they're probably just as smart as you
are and they're physically stronger what
would you do
it's Denver you okay you could you could
master a set of techniques that's that's
where martial arts actually came from a
bunch of models now monks you know spend
most their time meditating and just
hanging out and not a lot of time to get
physical exercise and they go places
that's a way of people eyes what else
there is actually you know you know they
they call the technology and techniques
and stratagems that allows us to sort of
put us all on the same level some of us
are smarter sinister
some of us are you know more persistent
than others but when it comes down to it
if we were all in what Hobbs called the
state of nature more or less equal and
so so he says from this equality of
ability to Rises hope in entertaining
our hands so if any two men desire the
same thing which nevertheless they can
act both enjoy what happens they become
enemies competition I'm not talking
about like healthy competition like you
know okay everybody split up into two
teams and now to play dodgeball for the
rest of the period that's healthy
competition right I'm talking about the
sort of competition that gets people to
we haven't talked about throw business
people cutthroat means that they'd
literally kill each other I think I
don't know if you guys know this without
in Asia particularly like in Indonesia
at places like that Coke and Pepsi
representatives used to kill each other
routinely because the stakes are so high
it was one way to get access to
resources and resources in this case
paper market now managing to get around
that survivor I'm one of the sort of
things that we want you probably try to
develop some sort of culture not really
fair but to help everybody because like
civilization started because every
people realize that
okay well I'm farming yeah corn
I can't also farm this this the submit
so yeah developer relationship based on
what we actually see if we look at
ancient societies they tend to be pretty
stratified and the Warriors tend to be
warriors and priests tend to be on top
and partners priest provides some social
or usually priests are tied in with the
traditional functions to warriors
because if you have a bunch of corn and
those normally acts down down the winter
streets down down the steep walk that
corn and you don't have warriors pretty
soon you're gonna be slaves of nomads so
it doesn't end up being equal in most
ancient societies again yeah that's a
really basic thing and there's like if
it's between barley cakes lamb chops and
I want the lamb chops and you want the
lamb chops bargain cakes
yes at the winery the homes are a big
part of it but what else do you do on
your land right what do you do with land
we don't do this mom yeah you wanted
money as a possible because you can farm
that and what you're not farming you
like fish or hunt game or that's so
families when they were doing out of the
rock here people have a park walkway in
for themselves proach on somebody else's
land on the American frontier you were a
problem especially to start eating their
food so food what else do we compete
over mates let's say mates in general
people compete over that and that
happens even once we do have a society
and level of competition can walk can be
very high walk past a supermarket and
what do you see that that's so of so has
broken up with so and so now they're
dating somebody else and they school
them you know it's all this very martial
language okay so mates yeah and this is
where we're going to get to why it
becomes so dangerous other animals
yeah that's right dear you know go out
they clash their antlers together and
sometimes they poke each other so many
animals do it sort of non-violence do
this repulsive language and a lot of the
part territorial they definitely compete
over food sometimes they could ketover
things like protecting offspring
you know like lions no the Lions are
kind of interesting they're one of their
one of the species that's like us within
the high level of what we call interest
issues accreditation that means that a
lot of the humans that die are killed by
their humans a lot of the lions at times
over - how does that well a couple bail
Lions come in and take over the pride
Anita didn't watch that a nature channel
or National Geographic what's the first
thing they do after they chase off or
kill all the whole big line they kill
all the other babies go to eliminate
they're almost rebuild ones they want to
destroy the bloodlines
- chimpanzees actually turn out to be
the most like us
predation chimpanzees will kill each
other over land they will actually do
something that has been occupied so we
have competition and a little bit
further
I mean Hobbes also thinks about this in
terms of enemy you've got something I
want or something you got a nice house I
would like to have your house the only
thing that's really keeping me back from
from taking it is whatever it's got some
Laurel set sign here and I'm the threat
of punishment and that's the way top
season so like it says it comes to pass
that we're an invader it has no more to
fear than another man saying the power
if one plant cells builds or possesses a
convenience e others may probably be
expected to come to care the forces to
just possess him to private not only of
the fruit of his labor but also of his
wife was living every ancient society
have that develops past a certain point
in slavery and some people are turned
into slaves very often through war also
driven through death people kill each
other so there's competition now if we
know that you are
yeah what do you think I should do so
what wouldn't stop at nothing to protect
what is that translate into stars like
my practical reason I know you're out to
get my stuff or my land my wife and
children
my house whatever should I do
kind of escalates the person that's
trying to get your stuff I mean I could
try to do a fourth buy it and make it
don't seem really unappealing go and
pray on the next place probably be
better off just waiting into the week
that's practical reason they're not all
practical reasoning as you know you know
nice stuff this is also practical
reasoning in an extent is not just to
individuals but two countries one time
ago when I was in elementary and high
school actually and it was just soon
after I got out of high school
about 1983 to 1986 it was pretty dicey
we actually thought we might go to a hot
war when Gaddafi his line of death you
know rhetoric we fully expected that we
might end up not finishing high school
or being drafted into the army it was
still for war we were training to play
in Europe mainly a fight that the Warsaw
Pact and Soviet forces I - I saw a tow
and our life expectancy that was a
comprehension their life expectancy was
30 minutes just slightly more than
intervention because we were actually
going to go out in front of me and as it
was expected and that people would
actually use tactical warheads and the
Russians actually we know this from
looking at some other stuff they were
actually discussing whether to go to war
their situation was weakening
yeah from about 1983 to 1986 that was
the cusp period where if they were going
to go to war that it would have what
kept them from doing that why do I
didn't commit each other well there was
this thing called mutual assured
destruction and it was based on his
premise that nobody could afford to use
me to the levels that you get let's say
here Russia
States and I want to launch a
pre-emptive attack as soon as I start
watching that attack instead of
launching at me so that kept us from
going to war this what Hobbs is calling
anticipation reason this if I do this
this will happen now if you don't have
nuclear weapons and it's just swords or
guns or something like that then maybe
when your enemy or somebody who's a
potential enemy is weak maybe there's no
police around and you know that person's
got a gun and you know they have the
attention to doesn't it make sense to
shoot when you could you know try to do
the thing I don't wanna hurt you how
does the after something pretty
important here now let's take this logic
a little bit further so you want my
stuff and I want your stuff and I've
been reasoning and thinking you know
maybe I should get rid of them they're
gonna be a problem
why am i able to do that right this is
what goes
the thing about having reason being a
human being
well usually given thanks to aren't you
so whether you have the same sort of
thing running through your head come in
it's kind of like a paranoia TV and say
oh this person once survived you just
busy like what you have that doesn't
give you a hundred percent let's say 50
percent each other - oh well that's
that's the state of nature we live under
without the social contract with longer
it breaks down and hot sex with the back
of the state of nature yes if we're to
write well they enter this reason why we
have a social show a contract yeah
because we realize that it's not a good
thing that we constantly kill each other
because you can walk but you're right
each other had is and that's a part of
our nature just like you know when I'm
killing each other you know we also want
to live in peace with each other so you
saw more like Aristotle or Thomas
Aquinas hops things that part of what we
do in the social contract is overcome
what are human tendencies
we go to this not because we say we
don't want to be the kind of people who
do this weather thing but because we
this is a very pessimistic view of human
nature it's interesting in saint
paranoia because but there are so much
smaller should have drawn a connection
between through the hop also another
borderline personality but more because
of stuff about me but now let's go swiss
Quebecers you know that that I'm flying
to kill you what should you do but I'm
part of including precisely because I
think that you're at you can take my
stuff
tell me first yeah so both of us now get
into this situation where precisely
because the other person is a human
being not just an animal because the
other person is capable of practical
reasoning of thinking things out
I got eliminate them because there then
there's a third thing that even further
raises the stakes he says men have no
pleasure but on the contrary a great
deal of grief and keeping company where
there's no power enables overall at all
why every man look at that his
companionship value him at the same rate
he sets upon himself we all want other
people to respect to fear to love to
want to hang out with to pick whatever
you want with us and you think that
people tend to overvalue themselves or
to undervalue awesome job how many a
little sick of all how many of you think
that human beings in general tend to
over value their own goodness nature how
many do you think that human beings tend
to undervalue very very few why do you
think people
yeah there are there are some people are
genuinely humble and then there are some
people that are more humble than they
want to be right this or second-guessing
themselves but most people aren't like
that most people think about when we get
in political arguments most people say
well you know I'm probably wrong about
this but I'm gonna throw this out here
anyway let's say this is the way it is
you guys are awful sort of tendency and
what happens how do you feel when
somebody doesn't see eye-to-eye with you
how long crush the others it's
frustrating sometimes if you have
problems with the angular it goes from
the frustration to anger very quickly
how could you possibly say that what
kind of degenerate are you think that we
also we all want people to value of us
any be like me
company is always in somebody's expense
plus it's hard to find comedy where
somebody isn't the blood of a joke when
you can make fun of yourself that makes
well he says on all signs of contempt or
undervaluing so remember what contempt
was for house contempt was not thinking
a not hating not loving something so
that somebody doesn't hate you or
doesn't love you they're less we are
preoccupied with other things more
interested in what's going out in their
life
chopsticks you're not gonna like that
and he thinks this is we want other
people to be sort of in our orbits we
want to be so what happens well this
makes us want to as he says extort a
greater value from his contenders by
damage
by example so very often people you know
probably remember this from like middle
school elementary school there are some
kids trying to get attention all the
time they do it the wrong way
ring a bell and you know the teacher
would say well they're just acting out
because they're not getting enough
attention at home or something like that
or remember somebody to pick on somebody
because they want to be friends with
that or guys are really bad at this they
pick on a girl that they like yeah
that's the sort of thing that Hobbes is
talking about you want somebody else to
look up to you to talk to you to to
smile at you to hang out with you and
you're going to get attention from them
one way or another if you can't get it
the good way they won't give it to you
freely whether you're for something yeah
the same that social contract isn't our
natural thing
well you good I mean you could have
displayed everybody right yeah then they
wouldn't really be honored to you they
wouldn't really think of you table
stakes they would because again I'm says
this very custom is to commune with
nature
where what does honor really means I
mean we're afraid of each other that we
recognize the judge power and so when
you're communicating is something again
we're like it resilient or to a mystic
stance Hobbs is right that had asked me
wrong
Hobbs is reducing things he's taking a
kind of dark the only way to break those
and to challenge his perspective based
on the social contract or natural
wanting of the social contract yeah
somebody like Aristotle thinks to me are
some things that social contract is a
natural thing for us yeah
generalistic we're here yeah Aristotle
thinks that there's sort of this is part
of what we are doing that means that
were social by nature we want to get
along but a bit unfortunately many still
up pops thinks that the conflict is at
the very heart of but let's see how we
did this but before that so we're in the
state of nature what does the state of
nature like he says state of nature is a
state of war instead of war of all
against all it doesn't mean the morale
actually physically fighting all of the
time but it means that we're always
prone to it there's there's no possible
check up that things could go walk with
it and he says whatsoever therefore is
consequence which every man is enemy to
having man in such condition there is no
place for industry because the truth
they rub is absurd therefore our culture
of the earth on navigation in the he
goes on and he says the thing that's
worse than this completely is continual
fear as if you have this dynamic going
on everybody that you see could be a
threat including into the people you've
managed to put under you maybe they
don't like being ruled if I try to do
you in as well too so it says continual
fear and danger of violent death and the
life of man is solitary poor nasty
brutish and short there's only one catch
phrase that you should remember with
Hobbes nasty brutish and short the life
outside of the social contract and then
it says now in this war of all against
all there is no such thing as
Justin I'm just given anything you like
unfortunately so can anybody else so if
you want what mr. Looby has it's a nice
jacket that he's got there thank you
now of course if he wants to resist you
he has a perfect right to do that if he
wants to get Miss Pacific to line up
with them to help them that's perfectly
fine too as a matter of fact if he sees
you eyeing up his jacket and he wants to
build a good fall or something like that
that's a-ok - in the state of nature we
could use force or it is fraud to
achieve our hands and that's that's
perfectly now this probably doesn't
sound like a place where you want to be
right the part you're used to living
outside of the state of nature who do
you think this might appeal to yeah
those who lust for power yeah sometimes
people are willing to shake the system
up so that they can hopefully come out
on top
can you think of any other people that
really might get into this this is yeah
this is what I want that aren't really a
part of society people from society
that's a good way to look at people who
don't derive benefit from being in
society they some people are hardened
criminals criminal organizations are
outside of the social contract pirates
how much so how we get out of pop says
the best motivator for this is fear only
reason rationality but it's based on
fear yeah this is the passions that
inclined men to peace our fear of death
desire if such things are necessary to
commodious living the things that you
like and full by their industry to
attain them so what reason suggests to
us natural law and what is this based on
so remember Thomas Aquinas is natural
law being is this a good existence is a
good you should try to protect life
Hobbes is saying well protect your life
her life his life worry about your own
life
so he says reason suggests convenient
particles of peace upon which men may be
drawn to agreement so I'm just thinking
that here's the way it works we're stuck
in this situation we can think and
reason we can say how could we get out
of this and we should all come up with
more or less the same answers because
all of us have reason more or less to
the same thing and what are these things
is a law of nature as a preceptor
general rule found out by reason by
which a man is forbidden to do that
which is destructive as a sort
preservation or taketh away the means of
preserving the same that's also about
self-preservation you need to not do
things that will get you do not do
things that will take away what you need
in order to live and to admit that by to
what you think is the main D
best-preserved so since we're stuck in a
war of all against all in the state of
nature what would be the first rule then
everybody should seek peace that
everybody should seek take it take it
out of this it's a preceptor general
rule of reason every man ought to have
never peace visible as far to see us
open patina so if I if I think for
example it's it where you know this is
warm all against all and let's say this
side of the room I think are more
reasonable more more willing to put
their desires you know out of play for a
moment I think these these guys they're
they're all bunch of hotheads and
troublemakers it would be reasonable for
me to try to seek peace
these people and to say these people we
can't see these as a matter of fact how
about all of us get together and we'll
form of the social contract in the
society and then let's let's let's keep
these people out because they're trouble
and then each one of you could probably
if you really were reasonable and
inclined to seeking peace you could you
could arrive at the same conclusion that
sounds really good most people these
people are okay
most people are beyond the pale right
and then you know when somebody try to
come into our society now if you if you
have hope of obtaining it then you
should you should if you don't have hope
of obtaining it then you just stay in
the state of war HotList think gives it
a realistic chance of getting out of the
state of war before you should buy into
know sort of idealism the second he says
the some of the right of nature which is
by all means we can to defend ourselves
it says when here's the second law that
a man be willing when others are to so
far as for the Peace of defense of
himself he shall think it necessary to
lay down his right to all things and be
contented with so much Liberty against
other yes
so now let's bring you guys back in here
you're no longer behind the pit we're a
society we're going to we're going to
put together sort of a set of rules
about what we should do it what we
shouldn't do
we don't want to end up with the state
of nature again because that's you know
nasty brutish and short what do I have
to give up my right to so you can feel
okay and safe in your life possessions
Liberty what do I desire to want
something whatever you want to I have to
do with actions not so much with desires
yeah like if you want something of mine
okay you have to give up the desire just
to go do the action action just because
I can I can desired as much as that Lex
was so that effect
kill me yeah give up the right to use
whatever vile means I want to well again
it's not so much about desires per
sentence about actions so what's another
thing that people tend to want to do
they shouldn't do don't you then make
sure you do anything you like to anyone
whatever you want to what else should we
give up property life and land well
we'll get to some of these when we get
to the other ones it's it's interesting
that's the other things let's look at
some of these other laws of nature the
third law of nature he says men perform
their covenants me so if you make a
promise like say a contractor somebody
you have to deliver it because if you're
not what are you doing you're putting
people back in the state of nature if we
can't rely on other people to do what
they say they're gonna do that you know
like let's say with I'm going to give
you some money today to give me some
more tomorrow
if you can't rely on them for that how
can you rely on up for this big promise
which is
these things you're not going to do
these things so it says we have to
behave in such a way as to be
trustworthy
now excessively interest in here those
are both the snakes sovereign we haven't
talked much about that one of the
problems of the state of nature is
there's nobody to actually make sure
that things go the way they show judges
there's no king magistrate said before
the names of just and unjust in place
there must be some coercive power to
compel men equally to the performance of
their punishments whether the perform
their covenants by the terror of some
punishment greater than the benefit they
expect to gain them region so we have to
have if the Hopf didn't things been
worth it social contract there has to be
some sort of authority and that
Authority has to have almost unlimited
power because if you start limiting or
then people are gonna start to do the
wrong things so how do you keep people
from killing other people well you tried
to kill down after you torture and evil
early modern times they didn't just tell
people dude do some stuff to that first
men because they want to show everybody
else killing is not a good thing how do
you do that make it you know they get
much more painful for them to suffer the
penalty stealing cutting off some of
these some of these can seems very
barbaric right it's still done in some
places but it's certainly a sense of the
strong message that's that it's dealing
break down the social country that's
what the song Hobbs of soccer fourth log
nature says when a man receives a
benefit from another of mere grace that
means that somebody's generous to
another that endeavor that he which
giveth that have no reasonable cause to
repent him it was goodwill now that's
kind of you know Florida you know 17th
century language what is he talking
about there somebody gives you something
you should be grateful
don't throw it back in their face don't
take advantage of them for doing Hobbes
thinks that if this is going to work
that's one of the things that doesn't
govern our behavior so don't kill don't
steal keep your promises don't be an
integrate doesn't seem to point out of
the same level don't kill them it does
but it's important if we want society to
them to work according to Hobbes that's
part of what we need lesson
fifth log entry says is complacent that
is to say every man strive to
accommodate himself to the rest so if I
have one set of political opinions of
you have another set of political
opinions should I get in your face and
shout at you probably stupid for
believing when you do try to boycott
your stores and sort of thing that would
be to put us back at the state of nature
with quicker because if I'm going to do
that you can tell I don't on review at
all why wouldn't I do all these other
bad things do you know I'm going to make
you angry and when you're angry
bad things for me that you what are all
the things we disagree about besides
politics religion okay
religion is a big one she wanted hops
people were killing each other burning
general duty to each other society more
Theory Hobbes actually thinks that in
this idea of society get rid of the
books of Aristotle because they're just
provoking people people are using those
to argue with each other about the sort
of stuff that's contentious you know we
don't want people fighting each other we
don't want people to be getting angry
politics recently yeah economic stuff
yeah this dissolve Occupy Wall Street
and also the mustard 70 Tea Party or
which are both angry you know what the
word family comes from right slightly
longer were it's a short for fanatic
because people it doesn't happen there's
a lot in here
here when we have riots over sports of
tends to be life the winning team for
the World Series
World Series and people in Milwaukee
1987 right now they're training over
cars and you know busting and windows
and bars and punching each other this is
not they celebrated winning pageants
that lost but you know what happens in
some other countries people go crazy
soccer hooligans beat each other they
get together just for the fun of eating
each other people tear up you know the
stadium throw the the seats at each
other okay some sports sports gonna be a
kind of a touchy thing we have religion
politics economics various sports
anything else people get heated
health care system okay you know there
was actually I don't forget to spot this
there was this is not exactly there was
shooting and an emergency in some
somebody within the emergency room and
somebody else saw them there and they
had their their friends there and they
brought their friends in and they shot a
couple shots luckily people just got
great security guard got hit and a nurse
got get they didn't hit the guys of
course because most gangbangers terrible
shots because they don't actually
practice shooting and but you know they
were willing to fight in an emergency
room I mean that's state nature stuff
that's not sort of in here time getting
angry about health care people are
starting to beating medicine as we
should what about celebrities people
ever get upset about or defend
celebrities will they find each other
anything look at angry so this is all in
front of complaisance
not doing that sort of thing not not
getting into contentious conversations
sixth law of nature upon the caution of
the future time a man lots of part of
the offenses past of those who are
attempting desires so we should be
willing to put the past behind us not
carry on with bad news let's skip down
in the 8th place for a law of nature so
this is what's needed
working society no man by deed word
countenance or gesture declared hatred
or contempt for another he'll be part of
the walk
I am our time and I have been trying for
years to curb myself my tendency to be
contemptuous some people's views that I
haven't I'm doing that myself
I see people constantly expressive
content for each other about these these
things that we just talked about
healthcare politics religion if you're
going to stay in a social contract and
not go back to the nature cops thinks
that this would actually be something
required probably if there's something
like a law against treating each other
contemptuously so we'll just be like you
know doping hate crimes like don't say
they have things to people they disagree
try to convince them without saying here
a dummy you're a terrible person that
would be violating the social contract
concepts and puts us puts us at risk for
being back in the state of nature
another one that he says is this is all
the way at the very bottom so the law of
nature that they that are a controversy
so that they're right
the arbitrator so if we feel that we
have been wronged and somebody else
feels that they have it belong to us we
work it out ourselves we should submit
it to a third party and have them try so
why do you think that's well you're
already convinced of your side they're
already convinced of their side yeah I
mean if you really have reason on your
side and that third party it's very hard
to do that because you know to be
willing to submit to a third party once
I to be willing to submit to a third
party it's sort of like a minute and you
could possibly do wrong is enough who
wants to do that anybody here routinely
submit their arguments to a third party
table stakes that's what we have to do
well when you do that to say you're not
looking for agreement again this is
based less on desires or how we feel
more on our actions so we're gonna say
we're in some dispute about I think the
cafeteria should be serving eight ball
songs every single you think I don't
think that's a good idea I think we
should have other foods
I said meatball stops that's it and then
he asked me why do you think because I
like Pete ball slugs
I want them every day okay now we decide
that we're going to say okay both gonna
present her case so his rent and she's
gonna hear him and she's gonna hear our
grounds and then she'll give a decision
and here's what we're gonna both promise
to do whatever she happens to say that's
gonna be the one that decides right so I
said yeah okay because I think of course
because you're rational people who
usually do and you and you think okay
she could maybe say sure me also have
some great but she's probably not going
to do that because this does not sound
like a really reasonable
well that that's one of the problems now
that's one that's all superwash of
nature he says here's your little loss
of nature if a man be trusted a judge
between the enemy so if you're gonna be
the arbitrator
it's a precept of a lot of nature that
he deal equally between so you're right
there's a sophistical hajikko problem
can you know that the judge is not
biased
you don't if the judge is doing that
they're actually violating the social
contract so pops would say you should
punch them pretty severe
that's I think we will be able up so you
see with Hobbes very stark contrast
these same here do you want this or do
you want this either way you've got some
trade-offs right here do anything in
life but there's no right and wrong and
everybody will probably pile on you
sooner or later
over here we live together in a society
we can better not do anything that
violates the social contract because if
you do so I'm gonna have to use whatever
force is necessary
so it's not just a matter of keeping
your hands off the floating people's
stuff or killing them you also ought to
accommodators like to submit your
judgments to an arbitrator there's a lot
of deal with this Hobbes thinks this is
the best that we can get top six that
this is the way out oh right
that's what it is this philosophy during
the activities so there's a real problem
I think you didn't see so who keeps the
sovereign there's no fuel all the
majority sovereign is no longer side
this is a big problem this is sort of
this almost four Simha kisses so that's
what we'll leave off